[Music]
scaling an application with kubernetes
is done with replica sets replica sets
ensure a specified number of pods are
running at any given time replica sets
are considered a low-level type in
kubernetes and are managed by our
deployment object which we defined in
the configuration file specifying the
number of replicas under the deployment
in our llamo file will create a replica
set and the pods it manages to increase
the replicas of our app running in our
coop cluster we change the value in our
configuration yamo file and reapply it
let's say we need to change to three
replicas to handle the daily demand of
our online travel service this results
in kubernetes creating two more pods and
as expected two more drones take off
kubernetes uses the declarative model
with our deployment configuration we
defined a desired state for our
application kubernetes constantly
monitors our pods and acts to match our
configuration so in addition to handling
expected demand on our application the
replica sets defined in our
configuration can also serve as a
blueprint for auto-recovery
why don't we see what happens when a pod
goes down
q brunette EES knows that it has to
start another pot to scale back down we
can just modify our configuration and
reapply how would our system handle
traffic burst automatically to be able
to scale more dynamically we need Auto
scale kubernetes offers a horizontal pot
autoscaler
which can automatically scale the number
of pods in the replica set based on the
policies the user defines we can define
a scaling policy with a minimum and
maximum number of pods to run based on
demand for the application another way
of talking about scaling an application
is in terms of availability and how we
distribute our application pods across
the infrastructure assigned to our
cluster it makes sense to cover that
next
you